efecto Krypton the exploitation of half
the world to become what it is how many
was will India need right his idea was
that look this is not in which other
large countries like India and China can
basically grow so what you're doing then
is then you're basically saying that the
most important task that these people
are doing which is really regenerating
your society is not valuable
and that's a horrible lesson a horrible
message to give perpetuates and this
kind of cycle of exploitation and
feeling that only way the only good part
that you're successful when you're more
successful in exploiting others and
exploiting nature that that's what makes
you successful and that's a terrible
message to give in terms of sustaining
the planet in something so I feel that
we had a situation where many kids today
have the supreme consciousness they're
aware that the world is in danger and
they're needing this moment really to
change the way we do things but there's
a there's a huge gap between their
consciousness and the consciousness of
the people who political and economic
leaders and that so that to me as an
anthropologist is going to be one of the
most interesting conflicts and struggles
that we are going to see in the next
decade or two
basically you created a situation where
you've solved globalization as a good
thing to people but they're not seeing
any other better and this is where there
was a failure of governance but it was
also a failure of ideology of the
economic system which
in a sense you know if you leave
capitalism the capitalist tildes right
that's my thing mark said you need you
need government because the government
prevents to the capitalist from
destroying there are the the boost you
know it's like the golden egg and and
the idea is that governments force
[Music]
entrepreneurs and businesses from your
shopping all the wealth and they
distribute some of it so that everybody
feels they're vested in the system but
this is what could not happen and that
is why we have I feel we have a
disenchantment with the political system
that we see all over Europe and are not
writing the question really is okay I
lost my job as an auto worker because
the companies moved abroad what did I
gain in exchange and the answer is not
but you know for most people they didn't
really gain anything their goods became
cheaper that's true but they if you
don't have an income it doesn't matter
if you defy you can't afford to buy the
very way someone's opinion me contradict
yours where's my friend Alan it's all
about your perspective who are we in
what is the nature of this reality
[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host down sake on we're on-site
at the American Anthropological
Association annual meeting in Vancouver
British Columbia this is our second
annual partnership with them we are now
going to be speaking to the incoming
president of the American
Anthropological Association from 2019
and 2021
we have dr. Akhil Gupta joining us on
the show thank you thank you thanks for
coming on the program
it's a pleasure I'm so excited to talk
to you look you'll want to start things
off actually by talking to you about you
know you have a very vast understanding
of socio-cultural anthropology things
like transnational capitalism
infrastructure corruption studying
agriculture contemporary capitalism
post-colonial allottee globalization I
mean this is you take a very macro level
perspective about the trajectory of our
entire existence over time so I want to
know your thoughts on specifically is
the most upstream issue that we face
that's causing all the symptoms of the
issues is it that we have feelings of
separation and disconnectedness from
what is actually the true
interconnectedness of all things you
could put it like that I mean I think
that one of the biggest challenges
facing us as anthropologists today is to
think about the major issues that are
threatening life on the planet right so
climate change is a big issue global
capitalism and the way it's going is
those two are related to each other are
big issues and a lot of the other issues
that have to do with inequality with
social relations with our connectedness
to each other are really tied to those
issues
because part of the reason why we have
growing inequality in the world and less
connectedness and less of a feeling of
empathy for example for others is
because yes feeling more separated by
the fact that there are growing chasms
there's a chasm between us and other
people between even within the u.s.
between the poor and the rich between
the urban and the rural and certainly
worldwide there's a growing chasm so
that even people in India or China who
are really wealthy live in bubbles they
live disconnected from the rest of
society around them and you know
sometimes they cannot escape like the
environment so they can't escape you
know the pollution that's rising to
incredible levels but a lot of other
things they can escape right so so
that's I feel the part of the problem so
and quality as a discipline we have to
basically come to terms with this we
have to say where is this leading us as
culturally and civilization really and
we have to say how can what can we do
about it
right and how can anthropology as a
discipline contribute to making things
better we also face you know the
extinction of species the warming of the
ocean I mean there's all kinds of
connected things that make non-human
life on the planet precarious
and the precarity of non-human life is
connected to the fraternity of human
life absolutely so yes it's so if we go
all the way upstream to how when we're
first birthed into the world rather than
being taught about how the breaths of
air are from what the phytoplankton and
trees breathe out and how the bite of
the Apple is actually powered by the Sun
and how that level of interconnectedness
we're now in the metropolis and there's
light pollution we exchange a sheet of
paper for the for the for the piece of
food and the level of just spiritual
cohesion and interconnectedness between
us it now given the exponential
technology age and these devices that
are capturing our attention is so much
more disconnected rather than
interconnected which is this kind of
first principle that if we felt that the
symptom issues that you described
inequality the divide between the rich
and the poor the pollution of the
environment that we live in all of these
other in the I feel are downstream
issues may be solved by this kind of
first principle do you feel like that
that first principle can we can
implement strategies that can help that
most upstream and what do you think
those strategies are yeah so I mean I
think here the interesting question you
raised is what is cause and what is
effective right and I'll be disconnected
from our world because of the way in
which we live in the Indies in the
capitalist world in which you know there
is a commodification of nature and a
separation of nature from from humans or
are we disconnected because we are
learning the wrong ideologies or the
wrong attitudes in our early life and
it's really hard to say that you know
that's really the cause because you much
of what we learn even about our
goodness to other beings and about
connectedness to nature we learned
through the ideologies of the system in
which we live right so in capitalism we
learned that nature is a resource we can
use it for our own benefit we don't have
to care about the earth right that's all
part of what the teachers are so so
people then you know kind of internalize
those attitudes and then they go out and
then two things that further this point
nature they don't care about other kinds
of non-human life forms etc right so
it's a it's a kind of very tight
interconnection and you can't really
separate the two because this is the
world in which we live in the world in
which we are born so it's not that we
can somehow change our attitudes to
something else
when in fact we are learning those
attitudes in our everyday practices
right so I feel that those are caring
for other beings caring for non-human
beings caring for the earth goes hand in
hand with changing the ways in which we
actually interact with each other in the
economy and in society and so forth and
we can't have one without the other and
one won't drive the other but they
obviously they support each other so
positive change and one supports
positive changes the other answer yes
it's it does seem like the positive
change on the most upstream one is going
to feels like will catalyze the greatest
change on all of the downstream ones and
then also by doing things like
rebuilding the actual environments from
a more indigenous first principle
understanding of our interconnectedness
will make it so that it's not like you
can even be born into these boxes that
are stacked up on top of each other and
the metropolis is where even if you give
to leave the metropolis to feel like
you're actually
interconnected with trees and plants and
animals and the beaches and the air and
all that type of stuff the stars so I
have another I have another question
because this is your your study in this
is is is very deeply unprecedented so we
need to ask you this question the way
that we've been globalizing over time
we've been moving to these metropolis as
we've been creating the wealth the
wealth is you know the cities create
wealth people move to cities for more
wealth and it takes people out of
poverty and that's the story that is
being sold to people to leave their
rural areas and go to Metropolis and yes
there are things that are there like the
most cutting-edge western-style health
care is there and the professorship of
the institutions and these types of
things so how do we figure out what to
do about the incredible benefits of
these concentrations of the of the of
the spirits of the brilliance that is
there that is going on there yet also
realize where globalization and where
capitalism 2.0 the next iteration this
human Center Nature Center
interconnected style of capitalism how
do we figure that equation out know so
far all the development models we've had
happy models that take the experience of
the West as the basis for development so
the idea is that in the UK in America
people moved from rural areas to cities
they moved the change from doing
agriculture to you know doing kind of
factory work in urban and then service
work and so forth and so that's supposed
to be the trajectory that everyone else
should follow in everyone else in the
world should follow if they are to
become rich and so on but of course it
was built on the fossil fuel economy
right so the whole civilized whole
industrial revolution
and the entire basis of civilization as
we know it today and globalization in
the world today is built on fossil fuels
and we know that we cannot that's not
sustainable
it will probably destroy the planet
before human the human civilizations run
out right there's a real chance that in
a couple of generations we could be
wiped out as a civilization so we have
to start thinking about doing
drastically things drastically
differently and whether that involves
urbanization or not I think it's an open
question because you can in fact think
about forms of urban life in which you
will use less energy you would be able
to you know live in a more sustainable
way etc but it's I think that's to me
less of an issue cities have a very old
history in you know like the first
cities came up in 6,000 7,000 years ago
but I think it's more about the idea of
living sustainably and living on
renewable resources and thinking about
not basically digging stuff up from the
ground and burning it which is what
we've been doing to have you know what
to have what is now called development
right so the question really becomes
like what alternative forms they might
be of development so one answer that was
given for example by somebody like
Gandhi who as early as nineteen hundred
and eight wrote something saying the
British form of civilization is not
sustainable right so he could see it
coming and he felt that this was not the
way in which the rest of the world could
live and his reasoning he has a famous
court which says that if it took Britain
the exploitation of half the world to
become what it is how many worlds will
Indiana
right his idea was that look this is not
a way in which other large countries
like India and China can basically grow
and so so the idea so his solution was
okay you build self-sustaining village
communities a decentralized form of life
and that's the way you build you know
resilient and sustainable life on the
planet but they've been other people
who've said no you know if you have open
centers then you can actually provide
people with a high call higher quality
of life and you can make it sustainable
etc so there are I think there are in
fact creative solutions and there are
multiple creative solutions might be a
mix of different things but the bottom
line has to be how can we live
sustainably and I don't think that
there's us enough of a sense of urgency
about that question yes and that might
actually be something that destroys you
know human life on this planet
it might not destroy the planet I
destroy your life you know kill you know
what this reminds me of immediate return
hunter-gatherers that's what this
reminds me of where you are so in deep
interconnection with the natural
environment around you that you go to
the patch for the energy the the food
the nutritional value that you need from
it just like if we were to do something
like figure out what the next for what
the free energy systems are that we want
to be able to use and then to and then
to let that patch that we took that
nutrition from regrow plentiful enta
flee and bountifully and then we move on
as these nomadic hunter-gatherer
foragers did and then now it seems as
though this idea of wanting you know we
want to we have this great vision of
to have a hundred billion humans across
celestial bodies and and exploring their
own unique endeavors into consciousness
where they can bring their creative
gifts forward into the world and end
maximize meaning and love and creativity
and all these grand visions but like you
said this key is sustainably doing it
sustainably and frankly a lot of the
so-called solutions about colonizing
other planets etcetera its carrying on
that same colonial extractor model and
that's not gonna get us anywhere because
a more of the directional arrow that we
go there with can be more about
exploration and fun and it can be
roulette and not so as much about
cloning ization or fear of asteroids but
rather about fun and exploration and
settlement maybe and also being able to
have the future in that sense but I also
appreciated your point about there you
gave like a myriad of solutions towards
sustainability and I really appreciate
how one of these that I think is most
central we talked about was that idea of
understanding the deep
interconnectedness of how like immediate
return hunter-gatherers live but also
regarding like what capitalism 2.0 looks
like or when it is actually centered
around humans and the in the environment
and the next generations the seventh
generation principle of the indigenous
these types of things that it looks like
something like an inclusive steak
holding system where it's not just that
the employees of a company and the shirt
and the investors of that company are
the only shareholders but that also at
least other stakeholders are like the
gig economy workers and like the
customers of that product and also the
community that that company is actually
headquartered in and everyone owns that
is part of that flourishing
and and then then you see the fruits
actually being shared of the next
technologies that are emerging and even
you know the question of which
technologies emerge so right now for
example if you're a really smart
undergraduate and you are at a school
like Stanford or MIT or whatever the
chances are that you will your
intelligence and your abilities will be
channeled to profit-making technologies
not necessarily the ones that benefit
humans the most but the ones that make
the most money and you know I've seen
this I've seen this as a as a faculty
member where students are channeled from
areas where they might be doing say
fundamental research and doing you know
like breakthroughs in fundamental
physics or chemistry or biology that
would change the way in which we treat
disease or to other things and their and
their intelligences channel from there
into startups right startups that
basically are there to make money but
they're not really doing things that
will fundamentally change the way in
which we understand the world or work on
the world so so you see that happening
already with universities are you know
becoming increasingly corporatized in
that very and they become profit-making
centers rather than sell to us for the
production of knowledge that is for the
benefit of all and that's I think where
a lot of innovations and a lot of the
energy of this generation is basically
being squandered in this way and that's
really unfortunate to see like the
economic machinery of civilization is
creating some sort of a pressure cooker
at people's throats that instead of
being able to do things like we're
lorenzo de medici during the Italian
Renaissance
patron - Michelangelo Botticelli da
Vinci to be able to express themselves
artistically and create the Renaissance
now we have like imagine Michelangelo
also trying to like grow his art on
social media trying write grants for
money and like it could happen that way
and so it really it's it's not everybody
can be seen as a circle stamp trying to
be fit through the square hole of the
economic machine there have to be
different vehicles for the foreknowledge
which now we see lots of children
exploring project-based learning around
the sustainable development goals or
emotional and social intelligence --is
and all these others myriad of ways of
learning but then we also have other
ways of being able to to produce the
next world so it's not just about
fitting this circle through the square
but it's also about things like reach
understanding that every you person has
their unique gift their a unique shape
it's a snowflake for the human to bring
their get forth in the world so how do
we design a social fabric that has a new
funding vehicles some of the old ones
like just patron artists right that
actually make it so that the the
fluidity of the social fabric is
conducive towards people actualizing and
bringing their gifts yes yes now that's
a huge challenge I think for the
educational system for the whole manner
in which we really get people from a
very young age to a productive life
and a lot of it is also about you know
what counts as being useful work so a
lot of the work that people do today is
not recognized caring for elders caring
you know like school teachers are poorly
paired in most first of all countries
except perhaps Finland couple of
exceptions and they're not they don't
have high social status you know and so
forth and then so what you're doing then
is then you're you're basically saying
that the most important task that these
people are doing which is really
regenerating your society it's not
valuable yeah and that's a horrible
lesson a horrible message to give and it
perpetuates that this kind of cycle of
exploitation and feeling that only way
the only good part that you're
successful when you're most successful
in exploiting others and exploiting
nature that that's what makes you
successful and that's a terrible message
to give in terms of sustaining the
planet and so forth so I feel that we
had a situation where many kids today
have this green consciousness they are
aware that the world is in danger like
you know Greta and and they're leading
this movement really to change the way
we do things but there's a there's a
huge gap between their consciousness and
the consciousness of the people who are
political and economic leaders and that
so that to me as an anthropologist is
going to be one of the most interesting
conflicts and struggles that we are
going to see in the next decade or two
the struggle between and it's sometimes
portrayed as a generational struggle but
it's really not so much a generational
struggle as a struggle between different
kinds of consciousness I love the way
you're putting that yeah because it's as
though then some somehow we have this
like archaic consciousness which is
let's continue doing what has
in working for us in the past which is
actually not sustainable it's not able
to support the next world that we want
build and then we have this new fresh
consciousness of the youth that see a
path towards that next world that is
sustainable that is driven towards
building of social fabric that maximizes
prosperity for all and um and I agree
that it's then in these next couple of
decades that we see this pull between
how the archaic consciousness loosens
its grip and the new fresh next
generation of consciousness comes with
the next architectures and it's good not
going to happen without friction
obviously but you know as Mark said yeah
and you a new civilization doesn't come
into being without destroying the world
I mean there's going to be government
and I see this as being a source of you
know we will see in the next two decades
increasing conflict and struggle around
this issue and it's going to divide
societies you know across the world so
in terms of globalization one of the
things that you know I feel has happened
with globalization is that people often
talk about globalization as something
that just started in the 1990s you know
and it's such a you you know US and
North American centered view of what's
happening in the world I was just
staying over at Byron's house last night
who's a South African and he was telling
me since 1650 has been you know
happening yeah and and even the whole
you know story of European explorations
in 1490 is Vasco de Gama Columbus going
it's itself a shallow history of
globalization because there's been a
much longer history of realization that
you know has been there for for a much
longer period of time so the way I look
at it is I say that there are different
phases
mobilization and the 1990s marked a
different phase of globalization one in
which which was neoliberal which was
spreading a certain kind of philosophy
of you know pulling back government and
allowing incredible concentrations event
to happen
and the failure of that even for a
country like the US Canada Europe most
countries in Europe was precisely that
in fact free-trade as most economists
will tell you free trade is a plus plus
five we were like everybody gains by
free trade and free trade in fact
created a huge new source of wealth so
there was a lot of new wealth that was
created by the agreements that launched
globalization but the problem was that
was all you served by the one percent so
what you have is a situation where
countries are getting wealthier but
people are not just the ninety nine even
is fifty percent of all new wealth
generated goes to the one percent it's
higher than that it's even higher than
that so so a median male income in my
place like the United States since
nineteen seventy are just flatlining
yeah it's flat so basically you've
created a situation where you've solved
globalization is a good thing to people
but they're not seeing any of the
benefits and this is where there was a
failure of governance but there was also
a failure of the ideology of the
economic system which in a sense you
know if you leave capitalism the
capitalist tildes right that's my hate
marks that you need you need government
because the government prevents with the
capitalist from destroying they're all
the the goose you know it's like the
golden egg and and the idea is that
governments force
entrepreneurs and businesses from
usurping all the wealth and they
distribute some of it so that everybody
feels they're invested in the system but
this is what did not happen and that is
why we have I feel we have a
disenchantment with the political system
that we see in basically all of our
northern Europe all over Europe and an
automatic now the same principle that
applies in ecosystems of trees where the
the the carbon that is being sequestered
by the ones that are very high that can
then distribute that carbon yes the
smaller trees is not happening in our
own social facilities exactly and if you
don't do that then people are going to
get this so the question really is okay
I lost my job as an auto worker because
the companies moved abroad what did I
gain in exchange and the answer is not
much you know for most people they
didn't really gain anything their goods
became cheaper that's true but if you
don't have an income it doesn't matter
if your goods are cheaper you can't
afford to buy the very way and nothing
else came into its place as well Renta
skyrocket insurance sky rock yes all
these other things go quadrupling in
price right and then you were stuck with
the flatlined income base yeah and so
there's been a real loss of jobs and a
redistribution of jobs so a lot of you
know white men in America that from at
the level of middle management and lower
have either lost their jobs or
downgraded their jobs and there hasn't
been so all in the name of globalization
so they're supposed to be benefitting by
this thing but they're not really many
many
are and many are not and then this is
kind of one of the big if you're trained
as an engineer all you are getting some
great benefits of globalization if you
are trained in the service industry you
are in dire need to be retrained as AI
and automation come and take over of the
area at what humans can do better than a
AI in robotics is becoming smaller yeah
and smaller over time yeah and so who
was going to own the robotics and the AI
and the substrates of the virtual worlds
and the neuro technologies and bio
technologies that we augment ourselves
with because those owners are going to
be the ones that then have this
potential to do some sort of a
bifurcation a speciation away from the
eight billion other ones that are deemed
as this what do we need
useless class for right and spiritually
speaking indigeneity would say you're
out of your mind I think that way yeah
this is all deeply interconnected yeah
no exactly so the problem is it's it's a
continuation of this trend so you know
if you have one percent of the
population getting all the wealth and
now you have robotics and UI taking over
the jobs are other people did and you
have nothing to replace it with no
meaningful work no retreat
redistribution of income what are they
going to do and so I can create even
more conflict you know so I see that
there potentially sources of conflict
that come from issues of climate change
and so forth but also that come from
economic inequality and the two in some
ways converge because the people who are
saying let's have a more sustainable
life are also saying let's have a more
equal mode of living right so we are not
because having a sustainable life is
only possible if you have incomes that
allow you to live with a decent way and
so now what we have is the function that
governments did before about for
redistributing income etcetera is being
taken up increasingly by private
individuals who are running their own
forms of government you know so the
large foundations like the Gates
Foundation etc they run a parallel
government system because they are
basically spread billions and billions
of dollars on things that they want to
do whether it's about malaria in Africa
or whatever but it's not in any way
coordinated or answerable to other
agencies that have been doing this for a
long time or the governments of those
countries or you know even the people
who are being created etc it's not
answerable to anyone and so it's not
clear to me that that's actually a
better way to do things because there
are no checks on it there are no
balances there's no a better nurse
within a larger version of the social
good yes and you're giving an example of
what is the best case scenario one of
the 1500 billionaires whereas there's
the purchasing of the 50 yacht or the
fifth home yes watch it cetera that is
also happening it really is if you are
sequestering the most amount of wealth
from the civilization there is a moral
burden to also build the next world
where it enables that social fabric of a
gift economy of the deep levels of
interconnectedness of bringing unique
gifts forth we have much more to explore
a few I'm so excited that you know
congratulations on being the president
of the American Anthropological
Association starting now it's a 2028 one
we're really excited to continue doing
partnerships and dives into
conversations like these into actually
architecting all the solutions that we
were talking about
sure that prosperous future thank you
yeah yeah think I look followed it
thanks for coming on that right I
appreciate let us know your thoughts in
the comments below on all these great
things that Akhil was teaching us
everyone check out the links in the bio
below to kill his work also to the
American Anthropological Association and
support them please also support our
show simulation so we can continue doing
cool things like coming on site for
these partnership interviews you can
find all the links in the bottle below
and go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world we
love you very much thank you for tuning
in and we will see you soon peace that's
a wrap okay thanks so much you know that
was so nice yeah yeah thank you thank
you
[Music]